bro did you guys see that video with
Ryan Reynolds okay so so Ryan both of
you guys are gonna see it Ryan Reynolds
basically came out like he's like we
don't really have anything for Deadpool
3 like he kind of he's talking about it
he was like I've been working really
hard trying to come up with an idea or
something like that he's like I got
nothing and then he's like he's like
sitting on the couch and he's like hey
uh Hugh Jackman do you want to play
Wolverine one more time and Hugh
Jackman's like sure Ryan and like Hugh
Jackman goes upstairs so Hugh Jackman is
returning as Wolverine for dirt cool
three and I'm so excited for this I'm so
hyped bro dude I am so excited for this
man because Hugh Jackman dude I grew up
on him the guy played Wolverine I'm
sorry I'm so excited people but it is an
exciting time it is an exciting time
especially because everything about
phase four sucks so now that we get some
really really cool news about what's
coming on 2024 this is really exciting
we'll have a video here tomorrow on geek
culture explain breaking it down talking
about it our theories thoughts the whole
nine yards make sure you follow if you
haven't already peace